hallo tom wie geht's
hallo lisa mir geht es sehr gut meine
frau ist schwanger
wir erwarten ein baby wir sind sehr
glücklich
herzliche gratulation
wisst ihr schon
ein junge oder ein mädchen wird
nein es ist noch zu früh
ja es wird ein junge
ja es wird ein mädchen
ja es werden zwillinge
in welchem monat ist deine frau
schwanger
im vierten
wie geht es ihr
ihr geht es gut sie hat keine probleme
hallo bernd du siehst mühte aus
ich bin müde unser sohn ist vor einem
monat geboren
er schreit die ganze zeit
ich kann so wieder schlafen noch
arbeiten
so wieder schlafen noch arbeiten
die ganze zeit müssen wir ihn füttern
oder seine windeln wechseln
hallo selber hallo mag ich habe gehört
dass du mutter geworden bist
ich habe gehört dass du mutter geworden
bist
ja das stimmt vor zwei monaten ist
unsere tochter geboren
vor zwei monaten ist unsere tochter
geboren
ich gratuliere dir herzlich
und wie ist es ein bisschen anstrengend
sie schläft noch nicht lange
alle zwei stunden muss sich sie stillen
oder ihre windeln wechseln
alle zwei stunden muss ich sie stellen
ich hoffe das wird besser ich habe
gelesen dass die säuglinge mit drei
monaten länger schlafen ohne aufzuwachen
ich habe gelesen dass die säuglinge mit
drei monaten länger schlafen ohne
aufzuwachen
und ein mann hilft er dir und deinen
mann hilft er dir
ja er hilft mir
aber er muss wieder arbeiten
er hat nur eine woche vaterschaftsurlaub
bekommen
wenn er von der arbeit nach hause kommt
kümmert er sich um das baby
und ich kann mich dann ein wenig
ausruhen und schlafen
wenn er von der arbeit nach hause kommt
kümmert er sich um das baby
und ich kann mich dann ein wenig
ausruhen und schlafen
und wie war die schwangerschaft
meine schwangerschaft war schwierig
ich musste oft erbrechen und ich konnte
nicht mehr alle lebensmittel essen
ich habe gehört dass schwangere oft
appetit auf essiggurken haben
[Musik]
ich habe gehört dass schwangere oft
appetit auf essiggurken haben
bei mir war das aber nicht zu
wenn ich nur an essiggurken gedacht habe
musste ich mich schon übergeben
aber es stimmt ich hatte lust auf
lebensmittel die ich normalerweise nicht
mag
aber es stimmt ich hatte lust auf
lebensmittel die ich normalerweise nicht
mag
zb fisch ich habe oft fisch gegessen
zusammen mit schokolade
ich wurde in der schwangerschaft gut von
meiner frauenärztin betreut
jeden monat haben wir einen ultraschall
gemacht
so konnten wir sicher sein dass es dem
baby gut geht
jeden monat haben wir einen ultraschall
gemacht
so konnten wir sicher sein dass es dem
baby gut geht
und wie war die geburt war es sehr
anstrengend
die position des babys war nicht gut für
eine natürliche geburt
deshalb hatten wir
termin und unser babys per kaiserschnitt
auf die welt gekommen
deshalb hatten
termin und unser babys per kaiserschnitt
auf die welt gekommen
das ist ganz schnell
langen
hattest du danach schmerzen
hat es tut danach schmerzen
ja aber ich habe von den ärzten
schmerzmittel bekommen
hallo kevin wie geht's
super unsere tochter ist letzte woche
auf die welt gekommen
so schön ich gratuliere dir von ganzem
herzen
vielen dank wir sind super happy
das glaube ich wie war die geburt wie
geht es da eine frau
die geburt verlief sehr gut die geburt
verlief sehr gut
meine frau hat die wehen bekommen und
als die fruchtblase geplatzt ist sind
wir ins krankenhaus gefahren
meine frau hat die wehen bekommen und
als die fruchtblase geplatzt ist sind
wir ins krankenhaus gefahren
im krankenhaus haben die hebammen sich
gut um eine frau gekümmert
gut um meine frau gekümmert
nach drei stunden konnte ich schon unser
baby in den händen halten
und jetzt hast du vaterschaftsurlaub
ja meine firma ist sehr großzügig
sie geben den vätern zehn wochen urlaub
obwohl das gesetz nur einen tag vor
schreibt
zehn wochen urlaub obwohl das gesetz nur
einen tag vor schreibt
das finde ich super so kann ich auch zu
unserem baby shower
das finde ich super
kann ich auch zu unserem baby schauen
anna
soll ich machen luca hört nicht auf zu
schreien
anna
soll ich machen luca hört nicht auf zu
schreien
gib ihm die babyflasche
er hat sich ja hunger er hat sich ja
hunger anna ich habe ihn gefüttert aber
er schreibt immer noch
anna ich habe ihn gefüttert aber er
schreibt immer noch
wechsel seine windeln
anna
seine windeln gewechselt aber er
schreibt immer noch
anna ich habe seine windeln gewechselt
aber er schreibt immer noch
gib ihm den schnuller
das hat funktioniert das hat
funktioniert oft stillen die brust geben
stillen die brust geben
zur welt bringen gebären
die wickelauflage
die babyflasche die trinkflasche die
babyflasche die trinkflasche die milch
die milch
der nike der schnuller
der new quay der schnuller
[Musik]
das kinderbett
das kinderbett der kinderwagen
der kinder
hagen das spielzeug das spielzeug der
pate die partie
der pate die party nicht vergessen
dieses video zu liken zu kommentieren um
zu teilen möchtest du noch weitere
videos sehen dann abonniere unseren
kanal jeden sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video